alors il y avait plusieurs objectifs
et
opéré un devoir de mémoire sensibiliser
ma génération et la génération de mon
frère qui a 18 ans à toutes ces
questions de mémoire par rapport aux
grands événements passés notamment la
seconde guerre mondiale et c'était
vraiment l'objectif premier et le
deuxième objectif c'était rendre hommage
à notre grand père michel galmiche qui
est décédé en 2014 et qui lui a été un
grand passionné d'histoire pour le coup
concentrer plus particulièrement sur la
question juifs pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale et parce que je suis quelqu'un
de très sensible et je m'interroge
beaucoup sur ce genre de choses et c'est
vrai que c'est quelque chose qui m'avait
profondément marqué et je voulais aller
voir vraiment l'horreur vraiment
commencer comment ça se passait là-bas
alors je sais il ya plus grand chose il
ya plus que les murs et etc mais on
ressent quand même encore ce qui s'est
passé quoi
avec des monnaies différentes et ça nous
fait aussi un petit peu relativisé sur
sur notre condition ici on dit souvent
que les français sont râleurs sli ce qui
est un petit peu le cas mon cas aussi et
ça me fait relativiser sur plein de
choses vraies et on voit la vie d'un
autre d'un autre oeil